en este vídeo vamos a aprender cómo
reconocer y factorizar polinomios
cuadrados perfectos digamos que por
ejemplo tenemos el polinomio x cuadrada
+ 6 x + 9 y alguien pregunta cómo
podemos factorizar esto en dos binomios
bueno si usamos las técnicas que
aprendimos en otros vídeos podemos ver
que necesitamos encontrar dos números
cuyo producto sea 9 y cuya suma sea 6
los animo a pausar el vídeo y a pensar
en esto cuáles dos números pueden sumar
6 y si los multiplicamos el resultado es
9 bueno el 9 tiene los factores 13 y 9 y
19 no es igual a 6 y 1 negativo más 9
negativo no es igual a 6 pero 3 por 3 es
igual a 9 y 3 más 3 es igual a 6 3 por 3
33 y podemos factorizar esto como x 3
por x 3 lo que por supuesto es igual a x
+ 3 al cuadrado y que es lo que tiene
esta expresión que la podemos reconocer
como un cuadrado perfecto bueno que
tenemos una variable que se ha elevado
al cuadrado y tenemos una constante que
es un cuadrado perfecto y lo que sea que
fue elevado al cuadrado aquí lo tengo
dos veces como el coeficiente del
término de primer grado
veamos si eso es generalmente cierto
digamos que tenemos a cuadrada más 14 a
más 49
aquí están sucediendo cosas interesantes
muy bien tengo mi variable al cuadrado
tengo un término constante que es un
cuadrado perfecto que 7 al cuadrado y el
coeficiente de mi término de primer
grado es 2 veces lo que fue elevado al
cuadrado de este lado
dos veces siete no podemos decir que es
77 así que podemos ver inmediatamente
que sí queremos factorizar esto va a ser
igual a más 7 al cuadrado y lo podemos
verificar multiplicándolo tratando de
resolver a más 7 al cuadrado y cuando
estás aprendiendo a resolver esto puedes
pensar que es tan fácil como decir bueno
esto es igual a cuadrada más 7 al
cuadrado pero no recuerda que esto es
igual a multiplicar a más 7 por 7
y lo que tenemos que hacer aquí es
aplicar la propiedad distributiva dos
veces primero tenemos que multiplicar a
más 7 por esta y eso va a ser igual a
a más 7 por a y ahora distribuimos el 7
esto es igual a más siete por siete a
cuadrada más 7 a
más 7a
ahora podemos ver de dónde sale 14 a es
el resultado de 7 a 7 y también vemos de
dónde sale a cuadrada y 49 y podemos
pensar en esto de forma más general si
tengo la expresión a + b y la elevó al
cuadrado es lo mismo que a más b por
amas b y hacemos exactamente lo que
hicimos acá pero aquí lo estamos
haciendo de forma general podemos pensar
que a es un termino constante o una
variable y si distribuimos esto va a ser
igual a más b x está más a más b por
esta vez y esto es igual a a cuadrada
estoy haciendo la propiedad distributiva
otra vez a cuadrada más a b
más ave
más de cuadrada
este es igual a cuadrada más 2 a b más b
cuadrada esta es la forma general a es
una variable que puede ser x o en este
caso a luego acá vamos a tener el
término constante elevado al cuadrado y
aquí dos veces la variable por la
constante y les quiero mostrar una
variante de esto si tenemos 25 10 x mas
x cuadrada y queremos factorizar lo nos
podemos dar cuenta de que es un cuadrado
perfecto esto es 5 al cuadrado y tengo
la variable elevada al cuadrado de este
lado y luego el coeficiente en el
término de primer grado es dos veces 5 e
inmediatamente podemos reconocer esto
como 5 x al cuadrado y por supuesto
podemos reescribir este polinomio como x
cuadrada más 10 x + 25 y en tal caso
podemos decir que aquí tenemos la
variable al cuadrado aquí tenemos el 5
elevado al cuadrado y aquí podemos ver
que el coeficiente
dos veces el 5 así que esto va a ser
igual a x 5 al cuadrado y esto está bien
porque estas dos cosas son absolutamente
equivalentes